petit port de pêche du marigot la carte
postale est habituellement charmante
mais depuis quelques jours elle l'est
beaucoup moins voire pas du tout à cause
des sargasses le paysage n'est pas le
seul à souffrir de la présence de ces
algues à quelques mètres de là les
habitants sont continuellement dérangé
par l'odeur j'ai les odeurs mais comme
chrome
ça m'intéresse mais pas pour les enfants
déjà alors quand on leur demande leur
avis sur la venue prochaine du ministre
de l'écologie à ce sujet il y a comme
une forme de résignation au moins deux
ministres et ex crainte mis entre
parenthèses bien il aura pour lui faire
quelque chose mais on ne peut rien faire
vous même les filets ça n'allait pas les
services en redescendant la cote petite
halte au vauclin la commune a connu il y
a quelques jours un arrivage massif de
sargasses du bourg jusqu'à la pointe
ceux-là on les voit et on les sent à des
kilomètres pour les touristes et les
baigneurs la situation est
catastrophique même si la plage
régulièrement nettoyés certains se
demandent si la visite ministérielle
changera réellement quelque chose s'est
passé ça va faire quelque chose mais en
tout cas cela situation elle est grave
parce qu'on sent l'odeur à la maison ça
fait deux mois j'ai acheté une telle une
télé puisque notre lait déjà tombés en
panne à cause de ça agace et là elle
croit fait la même chose
elle a déjà des rayures côté activités
nautiques
la fréquentation a chuté la présure riz
est alors durement impactée au centre
nautique du vauclin l'on espère que le
ministre fera un tour de table avec les
acteurs économiques
en tout cas moi j'aurais aimé qu'en tant
qu'acteur de
de la voile martiniquaise qu'il se
préoccupe de ce problème pour la voile
mais aussi beaucoup pour tous les
martiniquais qui habite en bord de mer
direction maintenant la commune de
sainte anne
aux salines il n'y a pas autant de sart
gasc sur la côte atlantique
mais l'on s'interroge tout de même sur
les solutions qui seront peut-être
apporté par le ministre et fera ainsi
aucun travail va débloquer des fois
comme je disais mais
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit suffisant
est ce qu'il est capable de nous dire ce
qu ligue a généré par les sargasses sont
capables de faire aux organismes et de
savoir est ce qu'il y aura donc des gens
qui seront forcées de quitter leur
maison pour protéger la santé et les
quelques années qu'ils le restent encore
aviv
nicolas hulot sera dans notre
département du 9 au 10 juin acteurs
économiques habitants et politiques
attendent alors de voir ce qu'il
apportera comme solution dans ses
bagages